so today I want to share with you a
extremely powerful natural remedy for
inflammation not just inflammation but
autoimmune diseases gut inflammatory
conditions
arthritis skin conditions related to
inflammation this is something you
probably have never heard before being
connected to inflammation and if you
were lucky enough to consume this
substance as an infant you probably have
already been experiencing the benefits
of this but for many they've never had
this substance so unfortunately they
probably are suffering from some form of
inflammation this substance has some
really interesting benefits for your gut
especially we are actually all born with
a very permeable intestines where
there's actually holes right into the
immune system so this substance actually
seals those Junctions to make them very
very tight this substance actually can
give you your immunity yes it can give
your immunity there's two types of
immunity you have the one that your
mother gave you okay and that's the one
we're talking about and then we also
have the other that is acquired and
developed over time by being exposed to
pathogens so this substance can give you
passive immunity in fact in one study
which I'll list down below it showed a
3X improvement over the flu vaccine and
in preventing the flu and one study it
shows that it can improve the gut damage
from NSAIDs and damage from H pylori and
improve damage from infections that
cause diarrhea as well as damage from
autoimmune conditions it has been shown
to improve muscle growth so it's really
good for people who have atrophy and so
all this is very very amazing but it
also has the ability to repair your
thymus gland okay the thymus gland is an
immune gland on top of the heart that is
like a training camp for your T cells
and this substance is colostrum
okay what is colostrum well colostrum is
the first milk that your mother gives
you when you're breastfed so the the
many many studies out there that shows
the difference between
breastfed infants versus those infants
that have been that the infant formulas
they just dramatic difference in
long-term Health increased risk of
autoimmune diseases increased risk of
allergies increased risk of asthma
increased risk of respiratory infection
increased risk of obesity and gut
inflammation and higher risk for Cancers
and so as you can start to see it's just
really important that if you are a
mother to breastfeed now unfortunately
many of us have not been breastfed okay
so we did not get the benefit of that
however you can get the benefit of
taking colostrum
even if you're older so I'm going to
talk about that but you should first
understand what colostrum really is and
what's in it
in fact colostrum provides the only
natural source of something called
transform growth factor Alpha and beta
now what is that that is something that
can greatly help regulate your immune
system and it's also good for tissue
repair colostrum also provides the only
natural source of insulin-like growth
factor one and two now what is that well
that is that substance that I just
referred to it has been found to reverse
the age-related atrophy of your thymus
gland because as you get older the
thymus gland shrinks okay so anything
that you can do to improve the thymus
gland would be a really good thing
and there's other things too like zinc
and vitamin D
but colostrum also can help you clostrum
has been shown to increase all the
different T cells that you have and the
natural killer cells that help you
prevent cancer and attack viruses they
can increase the macrophages which
actually provide a barrier for pathogens
colostrum is like twice the fat as
normal milk it's four times the protein
but it's 250 times more immunoglobulins
which are the immune factors that give
you your immune system and this can
greatly reduce your inflammation and
initially for an infant one of the very
interesting benefits of colostrum is in
the development of your duodenal Villi
those little tiny like roots on the
inside of your intestine so colostrum
helps develop them and so if you don't
get the normal development of those
Villi then you may have problems in the
future with absorption of nutrients and
then you may develop something called
malabsorption but there's something even
cooler about this colostrum because I
started doing searches on the
relationship between colostrum and the
microbiome this colostrum is extremely
rich in the microbiome the microbes the
friendly bacteria so really what this
first milk is doing it's injecting part
of the mother's immune system as well as
seeding the infant's gut with this
microbiome which by the way is about
roughly 70 to 80 percent of your immune
system so it's giving you so many
wonderful things and this is why when we
consume pasteurized milk basically the
heating kills all these enzymes these
immune proteins all the microbiome and
there has been some interesting studies
on even calves that are fed pasteurized
milk versus raw milk and there is a huge
difference in their overall health and I
will put that link down below you should
probably read it and of course another
reason why we have so many allergies to
milk right because our immune system
looks at this as something that is very
foreign 100 percent of all cows in the
U.S are given colostrum I don't know why
we don't give colostrum to our own human
infants if they're not breastfeeding but
I think that would be a very important
thing to do so make sure that child is
breastfed okay you may want to try to
find colostrum that comes from a goat
like goat's colostrum that may work
better than cow colostrum why because
there is casein and other proteins that
you may have an allergy to that could
create a problem but usually the goat's
milk and especially the goats colostrum
you're going to have much less of
analogy because goat's milk can resemble
more of a human milk than a cow's milk
relates to humans milk however if you
can't find let's say a supplement that
has the cluster from a goat then at
least try to find a form of colostrum
that is not over overheated okay and
there's there's several out there I'm
not going to give you Brands and of
course if you can't find those try to
find something that they have removed
the case scene to reduce the chance of
allergies now anytime you take anything
related to the immune system especially
colostrum always start with a very small
amount and test the waters because it
could stir up some immune reaction
initially so you take small amounts you
take a half a tablet right before bed
you see how you react and then slowly
have more and more until you're
achieving the dose that's listed on the
bottle don't jump into just taking a lot
because who knows if you have an allergy
to milk or dairy but colostrum can be
probably something that you've been
missing for your inflammation and
unfortunately with many of us that have
not been breastfed just don't have the
benefit of that immune factor that we're
given from our mother so we have to work
harder at building up our microbiome and
supporting immune system with other
things now since we are on the topic of
inflammation there is more to be said on
that in one of my videos that it's
gotten over 5 million views
I share a lot of additional underlying
causes to inflammation that you need to
see and I put that video up right here
check it out